saluden a los colegas después de un
largo verano y se preparan para el curso
escolar para algunos el primero de su
nueva carrera muchos de estos profesores
fueron contratados a última hora para
cubrir un vacío creciente en los puestos
de enseñanza cierre el dow le dejó su
trabajo ingeniero hace tres años para
convertirse en profesor y acaba de
aceptar un trabajo en una nueva escuela
de nuevos colegas nuevos alumnos un
nuevo desplazamiento así que si es un
poco estresante pero estaré bien rezado
pase sin formación académica en
educación el perfil de luli es atípico
pero este director de instituto lo ve
como una ventaja con eso tiene
experiencia laboral real y un amplio
conocimiento de las tecnologías en
desarrollo que beneficiará a nuestros
alumnos ante los miles de puestos sin
cubrir las autoridades francesas
decidieron contratar este verano a unos
3.000 profesores extras sin experiencia
como docentes sólo tuvieron que
participar en un programa de formación
de cuatro días antes de ser catapultados
al trabajo un proceso acelerado que deja
escépticos a muchos padres
nuestros hijos son lo más preciado para
nosotros no queremos ponerlos al cuidado
de personas que no tienen formación
formal porque cuatro días no es
suficiente para formarse en nada
el proceso de reclutamiento rápido es
por ahora temporal pero estos profesores
recién formados podrán pasar un examen
formal en la primavera para obtener su
licencia